Who is the god
like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The God
Who reaches down to unworthy people.
Well, good morning again church. I hope you had a great six days
of worshiping out there. Then we
get the privilege and blessing of worshiping together and here
on Sundays. It is definitely a privilege and a joy to
do that. And so take your copy of God's word with me
and turn back to the Book of Micah as we took a break last week
for Labor Day in Psalm 50. We're back
into Micah walking verse by verse through that chapter
three today.
As we get into it though, you might have heard about the
famous author named Mark Twain.
Yes, he was prolific writer, but Twain was
actually hostile to the Bible and to the
Christian faith.
Why was that?
Well, it was because of Mostly because of
the influence of Christian leaders in his early life.
See if he grew up. He knew ministers and
elders and deacons.
Who owns slaves and abused them and use the
Bible to justify slavery?
He also heard.
men using foul language
saw them practicing dishonesty all
throughout the week.
After speaking piously in church
on Sunday.
Now he had great influences his wife. His mother were believers.
But he was so disturbed by the bad teaching
and the poor example of church leaders that
he was bitter toward the faith.
Now most of us probably have people in
our lives that we could point to a very similar story. It's happened
throughout church history.
It's actually something we're going to see in Micah chapter 3 today.
Here's the truth. I hope you see.
If you get nothing else out of today, you can remember these simple
words here.
selfish leadership equals terrible outcomes
selfish leadership
equals terrible outcomes
these leaders, of course have a terrible outcome on the
back end of that. But really what we're going to press into today
is
those they're leading.
Have terrible outcomes as well.
Micah is continuing to speak God's words to
his people who'd been Turning Away throughout the whole
first couple chapters. They've been running away from God.
And here in chapter 3 God sets his
sights squarely.
on the leadership of the nation
look now chapter 3 verses 1
through 12 to see God's judgment on leaders.
And I said, this is Micah. He's saying here you
heads of Jacob and rulers of the House of Israel. Is it
not for you to know Justice?
You who hate the good and love the evil who tear the
skin from off my people and their flesh from off their bones who eat
the Flesh of My People Play their skin from off them break their
bones and pieces and chop them up like meat in a
pot like flesh in a cauldron.
Then they will cry to the Lord, but he
will not answer them.
He will hide his face from them at that time because they've made
their deeds evil.
Thus says the Lord concerning the prophets who lead my people
astray who cry peace when they have
something to eat, but declare war against him who puts
nothing into their mouths.
Therefore it shall be Knight to you without vision.
And darkness to you without divination the sun shall go
down on the prophets the day shall be black over them. The fear
should be disgraced the diviners put to shame. They shall
all cover their lips. There's no answer from God.
but as for me Micah says
I am filled with power with the spirit of the Lord
with Justice and might.
To declare to Jacob his transgression and to Israel
his sin.
Hear this you have heads of the House of Jacob and rulers of the
House of Israel who detest Justice and make
crooked all that is straight.
Who builds on with blood in Jerusalem with iniquity?
Its heads give judgment for a bribe. It's priests teach
for a price. It's prophets practice divination for
money.
Yet they lean on the Lord and say it's
not the Lord in the midst of us. No disaster shall
come upon us.
therefore
because of you
Zion shall be plowed as a field.
Jerusalem shall become a heap of ruins
and the mountain of the house a wooded Heights
now as we dig through this passage of first what
it meant 2700 years ago to those
original hears. We need to understand the reasons for
God's judgment.
Why was he saying this? Why was God
going to judge his people?
It was really three categories here in this chapter and
they all have to do with the leaders of God's people because those
leaders were supposed to be ensuring that
Justice governed all human relationships.
that what God Said is how this is supposed to work and they
were they were supposed to be in charge of that, but they clearly weren't
and first the category we see is unjust
judges.
One of the reasons God's judging them first. It's unjust judges.
That's these heads and rulers. He talks about in verse 1 and verse
9 this this was a national court system that
was made up of families and clans. It
goes all the way back to Exodus 18 with Jethro and
Moses when Moses trying to judge everybody and Jethro is
like no break him up into smaller groups give heads and
judges over each one of those it was almost like this
National court system kind of a People's Court
dentist, right like you think of how that works
in Israel.
So if anyone think about that if anyone should have been fair and
equitable.
It should have been these judges who
were judging family members disputes.
It should have been easy for them to make it equal to
no justice as verse 1 says.
That we're Justice Means to fairly give people what they
are do according to God's.
Plan what he says is right. That's Justice. It's
just aligning with What God Says is the
right way to do things. That's true justice as
Leviticus 19:15 says in the csb translation
says do not act unjustly when deciding a
case do not be partial to the poor nor give
preference to the rich says judge your
neighbor fairly.
Meaning just be fair be right according to what God
says is right and wrong.
That's what they were supposed to be doing. The problem was verse 2 says they
flipped it. They hated the good and loved
the evil.
Verse 9. They detest Justice they make crooked
the things that were straight God is straight. They make
they make crooked all of that stuff, right?
Everything God's plan says is right. They make crooked everything
else. It was the exact opposite of God's basic foundational
principles in his Covenant
for the way Hebrew society should have worked.
They just completely distorted everything.
And Micah vividly Illustrated that.
With this series of brutal metaphors that he is talking
about Flesh and Bones and
cauldrons and tearing up it revealed their
hard hearts that they were oppressing people
almost to the point where they were eating them alive.
That's the image he gives here is how how
terrible they were treating people.
Verse 11 even says they took bribes to give
judgments one way or the other they gave the wealthy
people good judgments because they could line their pockets while
the poor people just suffered further.
That's not the way judgments should work right? It's not Justice.
Which is why God says in verse 4 what he says about these unjust
judges. He says then they will cry to the Lord, but he
will not answer them.
He'll hide his face from them at that time because they made their
deeds evil.
So like the poor had been suffering and were crying out
for help from the leaders and they were not getting any response. Now, the
leaders will be suffering and God says I'm not even listening
to you.
He says he's turning his face hiding his face, which
is an illustration of what once was Covenant blessing
where God's face was fixed on his people now
he turns away.
It's how far they have fallen.
But remember selfish leadership equals terrible outcomes, right?
There's a second category here. Unjust judges
second category for God's judgment was unspiritual Prophets.
We see unspiritual prophets in this passage.
Look again at verse 5.
Thus says the Lord concerning the prophets who lead my people astray who
cry peace when they have something to eat, but declare war against
him who puts nothing into their mouths.
Very similar, right? They're getting paid to prophesy one
certain thing. They sounded authentic because
their profits and they had the right words to say, but
these were considered false because they LED God's people astray with
bogus vision.
It wasn't what God was saying because they were supposed to stand as
kind of conscience of Israel.
To look around and see above what they're
seeing in the the way the world Works to guys. This is wrong. This is
not right. This is what God wants they were supposed to stand above it
all but here they're in the middle of it all.
And they're pulled by who can give them the most money versus who
can't.
So God says actually you who once could
hear from God as a prophetic gift.
no longer will hear
Will no longer will receive a message from
the Lord you will actually Fade Into shame and
obscurity like the darkness.
You will not hear anymore because you've
abused the gift that I gave you.
The sign of God's judgment that he would go silent to
his people that's judgment on his people.
but again selfish leadership
equals terrible outcomes
Of referenced verse 11 a couple times, but look again at it. I
want to read all of it to show this third category for Why God is judging
his people.
Verse 11 says it's heads give judgment for a bribe. It's
priests teach for a price. It's prophets practice divination for
money. We've already seen that yet. They
lean on the Lord and say
is not the Lord in the midst of us.
No disaster she'll come upon us.
Now we saw this in Chapter 2 a very similar thought
right?
where they were
at that time the wealthy influencers it
was talking about how they would just go around they would steal land from people
and they were consuming people. It's a very similar idea
that that as they were going around taking things from
people. They said we're safe because Jerusalem
is our hometown and because the temple is sitting
right over there. We're safe. Nothing's gonna happen to us. We're God's
people
Same thought here.
That's why I chose the word unwise leaders
to describe them.
unwise
You might say the other way fools.
Foolish leaders why that word? Well,
it's because of what Proverbs 1:7 says
very clearly.
That the fear of the Lord is the beginning of knowledge.
fools despise wisdom and
instruction
Remember when we say fear God?
There is a little bit of Terror in that
idea because God is God and we're not
right. We should be afraid in some small
measure of that. But primarily when the Bible says fear God.
It's this idea of all inspiring reverence.
That he is worthy of me submitting to him because
he's so great. He's so glorious that is fearing him.
It's submission respect to him.
And so think about these mica3 leaders, right?
The judges the priests the prophets the ones who are being paid off
to say what they're about to say giving good judgments to
those who give more money bad judgment less, right Prof sighing
all these things to one of the other based on what they're
getting from them.
They thought they were fine even as they did all that.
Again, it says we lean on the Lord.
The Lord is in the midst of us.
Which they assumed was true because they had the temple next
to him and they had the Ark of the Covenant in there. They just assumed that
meant God was on their side.
Clearly weren't revering God or acknowledging God in
any way in their lives.
They were not fearing him instead as
fools. They're taking bribes. They're committing
injustices. They're destroying people's lives. They're doing all
of those things and yet still saying. Yeah God's with
us.
They'd forgotten.
That God made his presence contingent not
on a location but on ethical
Behavior.
And here's what I'm talking about.
All the way back at Sinai Mountain where God gave
Moses the Ten Commandments and then called them
to leave to go into the promised land. This is
what God Said Exodus 33 verse 3. He says
go up to a land flowing with milk and honey like you get to
go to the promised land.
But I will not go up among you.
Lest I consume you on the way for you
are a stiff necked people.
Stiff necked that word means rebellious.
Sinful, it means they had been running away
from his Covenant commands and he says
I just need you to go to your room for a while as I
can. Remember that your your mom is really angry right
now and just needs to get away from you for a second, right? That's the
same kind of idea. God says I don't want to be with you.
Because I don't want to hurt you. I love you that much first of all.
But at the same time you see his presence was contingent.
On what they were doing?
Not that they had the temple or the Tabernacle or the Arctica,
whatever it was. They were like no, this is what I'm calling
you to.
That's why the Judgment of God was coming on these people and
Micah 3.
They were doing all these things and saying yeah. Well
God's with us. That's why verse 12 shows us what God's gonna do.
He says therefore because of all of that
right because of what they've been doing and saying God's with us and
not fearing him at all because of you Zion should
be plowed as a field.
Jerusalem should become a heap of ruins.
And the mountain of the house a wooded height.
in other words this mountain
that was once a stronghold.
a safe City
Where they would run to and they'd be safe and that was where God
protected them. And it was God's Hometown in essence
all of that. He's saying I'm willing to lay it to waste.
Because of what you're doing.
Because how you're leading these people.
selfish greedy foolish
selfish leadership equals terrible outcomes, right?
Now think about those people who are hearing this.
in the moment
hard to hear
those leaders would have been convicted hopefully.
And thankfully here's what we have. We have a record of King
Hezekiah and his people responding to
this very message in Repentance.
You can go read it. It's in Isaiah. 36:37 Jeremiah
26. You can go read the story of how God
used this message from Mike and probably
Isaiah too to preach to them and they responded and
God delayed judgment on Judah for about a hundred years.
So this actually did get through to a few people.
But we need to then think. Okay. How does this translate 2,700
years forward to us today.
How do we bring this into an apply these
principles to our lives?
Okay. Well we have to think first. What's the context we have
to remember some really critical pieces of this.
Because it's not a one-to-one thing here and we'll see how
we can apply it properly today.
Here's the biggest part of this.
Remember that Micah was talking to a theocracy.
It's a big word that simply means a nation that is
under God's complete rule.
supposed to be
and so they were set apart as God's distinct people
meaning he was to Reign. He was to rule they would have his laws
as their laws. All of that was a theocracy. That
was what it was supposed to be.
But I want you to hear me.
That's not America.
That's not any other Nation today.
So we can't go one to one and say this is
how it has to be here. If anything what we're talking about is
the kingdom of God.
That that's the parallel here. That's including anybody
who has faith and anyone
who will have faith in Jesus Christ forever. Whoever it
is, right? That's that's the kingdom of God. That's a super
Nation above any other tangible Nation
here. And so we see that that's how we can directly apply
spiritual principles from Micah 3.
Right, those those things matter right the priests and Prophets so
still carry over obviously into our church
life our religious life.
that just like Micah was
calling out those who are fraudulently fulfilling their
functions as priests and Prophets. He was he was all
for calling him out and we can too as we'll see in
a moment. But this other side is where the question comes.
This Justice side the physical day-to-day
how we apply that here
into our lives. Can we?
In a secular society like we live in now, how
do we apply these things? Well, I
think I think we can if we're careful. We can apply some
of these things into our daily lives because
here's the reality God is just right God it is part
of his nature is just meaning he's right.
He sets the world to work in a certain way a
right way.
And so we can align things as
best we can with what God says is right and that's gonna
work whether they're Bible verses for laws or not. It's
still inherently is right and wrong according to
what God says, right.
So we can we can pull those things in even in
the world. We live in.
carefully
But again, we can think first and foremost.
About this super nation that we are a
part of.
and if God's people who were his kingdom people
were judged
or at the very least discipline by the Lord for
what they were doing like shouldn't we want to avoid that?
I know we talked disciplines good.
But don't we want to avoid discipline? I mean
we want to avoid it if we can't we don't learn the principles before we get to the
discipline. That's good. We want to avoid that. So how do we do that? How
do we avoid what this judgment on them was?
What it was coming to them. How do we avoid this today?
So I see four at least four ways from
just this chapter that we can utilize
in our lives to avoid this
kind of thing happening for us.
first
We must defend the image of God.
You saw it with these leaders, right?
It says they were eating up.
Eating up the people.
Because what they did is they saw these people merely as
resources to consume not people
to cherish.
They were resources to consume not people
to cherish. Is that not the same thing that's
happening in our society today?
Where where people become resources?
things to be used
instead of treated as the reflections of God
that they actually are.
Here's what I mean.
Just think of the consumer society that we live in.
Where companies use the sexualized body
to sell everything from soap to hamburgers to appliances.
It's a thing to be used to be
consumed.
Even children are manipulated psychologically by
companies through advertisements and commercials
so that they are forcing their parents to buy
more stuff.
all in there
because that's a that's a thing to be consumed.
the multi-billion dollar pornography industry
It results from consumer demand.
Where it depicts human beings as objects to satisfy
your desires.
We have first-person shooters and
other violent video games.
Where a person gets numb to the reality that
walking around shooting image Bears is not okay.
Because it's a thing.
You have professional athletes destroying their
bodies for fame and for money. You have all and then
Then you have abortion.
Which often targets ethnic minorities?
the poor
and people who live in Edmond who want to keep up a perfect image.
Now I know.
As I talk about this there are a few triggers
and people's hearts right now. And so I
want to
I know there's extenuating circumstances. We can talk through those that's
Reality, and I want you to hear me.
Very clearly if you have had an abortion or been
involved in abortion in any way.
Your loved here.
Jesus loves you.
Don't have to stay in the shame.
You don't have to stay hidden.
He wants to heal you.
He wants to walk out of that and you walk and
wholeness again, he doesn't want you to feel the regret and
shame anymore. He wants to love you out of it. And that's
what we want to be about too. So as I talk about this, that's
what I hope you hear.
But it's a result that very thing is a
result.
of a culture who values convenience and
freedom above
The value of that life supposedly safe inside
the mother's womb.
Here's the reality.
a consumer society that abuses
the image of God
will eventually consume itself.
And God will not stand idly by at
the violation of his moral order.
he is just
he will bring Justice.
That's why we must be different Church.
That's why we as his people must be different. We
must defend the image of God in all people. We must
treat them fairly treat them equally, it must be
Justice. That's one of our values compelling love. It
starts with this reality that we demonstrate the love of Jesus
by treating everyone and respecting the
Dignity of every person.
It's Genesis 1:27 all people created an
image of God.
I know that that image is Tainted by sin, but
it's still there.
It's still in every person so we
ought to treat everyone like that's true.
As God wants them to be treated again. That's Justice. What
does God want us to do with that person? That's right living.
So that means we don't play favorites.
That means we're Fair. We're Equitable. We're we're
looking out for the wealthy and for the poor we're
looking out for the babies. And for the elderly we're looking
out for every ethnicity. We're carrying deeply
for people because that's the way God says it works.
Because every person has the image of God.
So we as his people must defend the
image of God in every person.
Doesn't mean we agree with everything everybody does but we defend and we
look for the way to love them the
best as God says.
That's the first way we can avoid this.
Second we must hold leaders accountable.
We must hold leaders accountable.
Now we could Venture into the the line of Civic leaders
here and there'd be much to apply over there. Of course, yes, but
but we're going to stick primarily with this super Nation side
with the church here kind of that world as
we apply this first.
Because remember in in Micah Theocratic era.
There were unwise evil religious leaders
who were consuming people. They were greedy. They
thought there was no consequences for their
actions. They just did it because it was in their hearts to
do it. Do we not see similar things happening in churches all
around us today in America?
Around the world too. Like this is the church at large. We
see some pastors abusing their Privileges and getting
rich off of their people.
Or sexually exploiting church members and covering it
up.
You see Larger than Life figures.
Who who are promoted as king-like and
they're untouchable?
It's because they're so successful.
When behind the scenes they're acting worse than unbelievers.
Like this cannot be Church.
Integrity not matter
Integrity matters along with that we must
also not idolize leaders where we Elevate
them to an unhealthy place.
Listen, the realities that none of us can be above accountability.
none of us
Not me. Not you. Not anybody. We are not above accountability if
I'm walking in sin.
Then I must be humbly willing as anyone else
should be to repent and to humble myself to
make it right.
Someone should be able to come to me and say here's what
I saw. Here's what I said what I I'm
recognizing in your life and and I have to be willing to receive
that and be accountable to that.
I'm not above a standard. You're not above a standard. No one is.
We also look at this and we see these false prop.
We're In It merely for the income
For the prestige they were building their own little K kingdoms, right?
They were they were wanting to have selfish desires fulfilled
by this position. But the reality is
faithful church leaders must be in it for the Lord. That's
it.
No other reason.
Because think about these guys, they weren't saying things because this person
paid him certain amounts of money. They weren't saying the right thing. It
must be no matter the cost. These prophets had
to speak God's word.
We must do what God says to do
no matter what it costs us.
That's why we put spiritual qualifications as primary.
Above whether somebody can preach or sing or
whatever else it's spiritual qualifications first and foremost. That's
absolutely number one.
Because we see selfish leadership equals terrible outcomes,
right?
We must be willing.
to hold accountable
and be held accountable.
according to God's standard
There's a third way we avoid God's judgment.
We Proclaim God's full word.
Third we Proclaim God's full word.
so remember here in Micah 3
these leaders wrongly assumed that nothing was wrong.
They're all good.
God's on our side
many people around us
have similar wrong beliefs about God and about
how life works.
And they believe these things because a generally
religious culture allows people to kind of walk down that road.
But also because they probably had a leader at some point in their
life. Tell them this.
And this is true. This is the way it is.
Let me give you a couple examples.
We have people who have grown up believing that baptism guarantees
your salvation. No matter
how far from God you walk the rest of your life.
We have people.
Who say God Bless America with zeal?
Yet every day go out and live selfish unjust
immoral lives.
We have people who have been duped into believing that church attendance and
giving money will result in God's hundred-fold blessing
in your life.
you'll get rich if you give
we have people who believe that if they voted one certain way in
the election, then God certainly loves them.
And he doesn't love the other side.
We have people who believe that if they're just a good person then certainly
nothing bad will ever happen in their lives and how
could bad things happen to good people?
every one of those
And many many more have missed the overall
picture of what it means to please
God.
We've made it something it's not that's
why here we go.
That's why we dig into God's full word.
That's why we dig into even the hard stuff the parts about
God's judgment even not just God's blessing
where everything's good. Everything's fine. And and you're gonna be a conqueror
and you're gonna be doing it all great. Like that's not
we have to also talk about his holy character his holy nature.
This is who he is. That's why we preach through the
whole series about Jesus in his character at
the beginning the year who he was is and always will be we need
to see who he is. We need to see The Parables teach us about
the kingdom of God that is radically different than our kingdom here. We
need to see my cat tell us who God is and our
response to him. That's why we do this because it
gives us to an understanding of who God is
Which then leads us to better understand who we are in light
of that.
And it leads us to see that aligning our lives with
What God Says goes. How his his standard
is that's the way life works best.
That's why we need to see what his word says, even if
it leads us to difficulties and struggles that's best.
Because we're aligned with God.
Listen, that's the nature of faith.
That's called Faith, right?
Where we say?
God your ways better than mine and I'm trusting you
that no matter what comes this this pathway. You're asking
me to walk. I will follow you.
It's faith.
Which in fact is what Hebrews 11:6 says?
Please God.
Without faith. It is impossible to please him.
Faith is what starts this?
For whoever would draw near to God must believe that he
exists. That's faith and that he rewards those who seek Him
meaning. I'm going to seek God in faith, and
he's going to give me what I need.
I have to believe him and trust him and have faith in him to
follow him.
but I'm going to
we only get that kind of stuff.
Because the rest of Hebrews 11 shows us some pretty hard things
people walk through because of faith we only get there when we
talk about God's whole full word.
That's why church we must speak only what
God has said and all that. God has said.
It's a good way to think about it speak only what
God has said and all that. God has said that will
lead us to please him and to rightly believe what
we should believe about him.
But there's one more.
One more way to avoid this judgment that
Mike declares in chapter 3.
It goes back to what he's rights in verse 8.
Remember he had just talked about these false prophets?
How they're going to go dark.
shame
Verse 8, but as for me Micah says I
am filled with power.
With the spirit of the Lord with Justice and
might to declare to Jacob his
transgression and to Israel his sin.
Now don't misunderstand what Micah's doing. He's not standing back here in
judgment and arrogance over God's people. He's standing there in
Humble boldness. Why because he's filled
with God's spirit.
That's what led him to say what he said. That's what led him in
his original call to be a prophet. He felt this
feeling of humble boldness because God said,
here's what you're going to do.
And he knew my whole life is to please God and he
was filled with his Spirit to do one thing. You saw what he said.
to Proclaim to God's people What God Says and even
if that includes sin and transgression
That judgments coming. He was supposed to say what God
Said.
That's why God says I'm going to bring you power to do it.
I'm gonna give you the power to do this role when
couple that with verse 8 when he says might
He says Hey Micah, I'm gonna give you everything you need to do
this hard task. I'm calling you to do. It's very similar to
what God told Jeremiah and Jeremiah 1:17 through
19. He says you Jeremiah and
this is calling Jeremiah as a prophet. He says.
You dress yourself for work.
The original King James said gird up your loins,
which is a weird way to say that I don't know if we talk like that
anymore, but this is what he said dress yourself or get after the task.
I've called you to dress yourself for work
prepare arise and say to them everything I command you.
Even the hard stuff.
Do not be dismayed by them lest. I dismay you
before them. Meaning it's going to be hard don't be dismayed because
Verse 18 I will make you this day a
fortified City an iron pillar bronze walls
against the whole land against the kings of
Judah. It's officials. It's priests and the people of the land right
just like Micah. He's facing these leaders who
are opposing everything he's saying and he's saying
What God Says
verse 19 they will fight against you.
But they shall not Prevail against you.
And see why.
For I'm with you.
God says to Jeremiah, it's gonna be hard you're gonna say some
hard things. They're gonna hate you.
I'm with you.
I Am with You declares the Lord to deliver you.
As a prophet of God Jeremiah knew he's
facing hard time. Micah knows he's facing
opposition and he says, okay.
God says, okay. I got you.
I'm gonna give you power mind give you everything you need to fulfill the
calling. I've called you to fulfill and that's the same
thing for you and me Church.
Because Micah says filled with the spirit mean I'm
filled with power and might to do this same thing
second Timothy 1 7. God gave
us not a spirit of fear.
but of power
and love and self-control
spirit of God brings power to fulfill
this call, but notice in verse 8 that filling the
spirit didn't just bring power. It also brought Justice in
Micah's life.
What that filling of the spirit did for Micah see now understood
God's right way how things should work and he began
to apply it in his life and other people's lives around him.
the same for us today
as we are filled with God's spirit which
by the way happens at conversion.
You're you're planted the the seed of The
Inheritance to come as planted in you called the spirit of God.
You have the spirit and you're more filled with the spirit
throughout your life as you submit control.
You are filled more and more and
more where he's in charge and you're not.
As that happens you begin to align yourself with
God's plan and you begin to help other people align themselves with
God's plan.
It's Justice.
You're filled with Justice as you look more like
him and you help other people look more like him as
well. That's God's standard. Not your extra biblical
concerns. That's not your pet issues. You're not aligning people
to those things. You're aligning people to God's
right way.
How to love people well according to his way that's
what we are filled with the spirit to do.
And that church is the leadership.
that we need
Spirit-filled
Standing for the right ways.
willing to
powerfully call out sin as needed.
That's what we need to be about and every one of us need to
be about that. Not just those who are up here leading those teachers every
one of us because here's the reality you're leading somebody.
Every one of you has somebody that's following you
and you're leading them. Either to God's standard.
Or away from God's standard.
so high call
but God's called this an empowered us to do it.
I want to dress one more thing though today.
Says I've talked about all this today. I've been talking about church leaders religious
leaders and
And I know that some of you.
Have been hurt by leaders.
In a church somewhere in the
past.
50 years ago 20 years ago two years ago.
And listen, I wish I could go back and change that for you.
I wish I could go back and restart re-correct
that whatever happened the way you felt. I wish
I wish I could do that.
can't
and so as I was praying through and writing this
my hope today was that this might bring a measure
of healing for you.
that we I
are trying to seek God's standard.
We see it.
challenged by it
Not perfect at it.
but wanting to be
progressing towards this
yet. I also know how trust works.
I trust is really easy to destroy.
And it takes a long time to build.
And so I know with those things that have happened in your past.
there might be
even you're on your last thread right now
and you don't even trust any church leaders anywhere.
I get it.
But hear me.
Even if you don't trust any anyone.
You can still trust Jesus.
He's the perfect leader that you need.
He will always do things the right way.
And he will never let you down.
You might not understand it might hurt. He will never let you down.
Because listen he went through something very similar.
first Peter
chapter 2 verses 21 through 24 describes Jesus going
through something like it.
Innocent but attacked
Listen to his example.
And then the result for to this you've been called because Christ also
suffered for you leaving you an example so that
you might follow in his steps.
Notice how you are to follow he committed. No sin
neither was deceit found in his mouth. He's innocent when
he was reviled. He did not revile in return.
When he suffered he did not threaten, but he
continued here it is. He continued in trusting
himself to him who judges justly.
Wrongly accused wrongly attacked and he says father you're
gonna you're gonna start this out.
You are the perfect judge. You will take care of this in
your time in your way. All I'm
called to is to be faithful.
And look at the result.
24 he himself bore our
sins in his body on the tree that we
might die to sin and live to righteousness by
his wounds. You have been healed.
No matter what has happened to you.
No matter what you've done.
Because of the cross of Jesus his life death and Resurrection,
you are healed if you place your faith in him.
There's no more shame. There's no more suffering. Eternally
you are in him. That's
what that means. So keep trusting him.
You don't trust anybody yet. Trust him keep trusting him
put your life in the hands or the one who knows it all
and he's gonna fix it all.
Trust him keep trusting him.
Hang on to him. You you are going to get hurt again at
some point. Keep trusting him.
Don't let go of Jesus because he's letting he's
not letting go of you. He's holding on to you. So don't
let
go keep trusting.
And trusting and keep trusting him and then church. Let's be about
this kind of Lifestyle.
That Micah describes against let's be
the opposite.
Let's be a church. That's safe.
Must be a church that loves people deeply.
sacrificially
Let's be a church.
that knows
our leader deeply
and live differently because of it.